and I ended up dating this guy that was
the allstar of the gym and he was like a
UFC prospect that's time and well what's
[ __ ] up is he was abusive
where he was abused or physically
abusive I was an abusive relationship
and I was stuck with him I was took on
lease with him so financially I was
[ __ ] politically I was [ __ ] because
my coach told him told me not to give
him locked up in jail because he was
like the next guy yeah what's his name
say his [ __ ] name did he even get to
you see nope he end up turning into a
stripper thai stripper this was just
[ __ ] do you just want dicks now huh
look at that this guy named Mike Wade
Mike Wade you [ __ ] [ __ ] you probably
kill me payment me a person but you
don't live in California mo [ __ ] and
yeah yeah [ __ ] you Mike wait wait on
deez nutz [ __ ] oh god he's probably
still really buff cuz he's a stripper
he's a [ __ ] stripper he's doing
steroids he's selling coke I don't know
what the [ __ ] else he's doing but he's
not winning at life at all yeah so yeah
he was [ __ ] abusive and um I try to
[ __ ] leave and there was just so many
ways I was [ __ ] financially I was
stuck with him on a lease and the thing
is the lease wouldn't let me out I was
co-signed with him because his credit
sucked and I had awesome 800 credit
score [ __ ] so they took the average of
600 and that's how we even got the
apartment so we lived together and he he
ended up having a [ __ ] DUI so I had
to drive him around and [ __ ] and then
we're stuck on this damn lease and he
wouldn't sign me out the only way I get
out of the lease is be signed out or I
would have to pay a $3,500 termination
fee which I didn't have and my parents
didn't know I was living together with
someone because my parents were
traditional and they're like you can't
of course live with anyone until you're
married type of thing so they didn't
know any of this and I would keep a
secret and the next thing you know
I can't get him locked up because of my
gym and my career if I get him locked up
and [ __ ] up my coach that [ __ ] up my
career in turn of that and on top of
that I couldn't get out lease unless I
had a police report but I'm not allowed
to lock him in up in jail because I'd be
[ __ ] politically and my career why so
I was just [ __ ] all the way around and
I was just trying to think of a way out
and I couldn't and at first you know it
was crazy like he was everything went so
well for the first eight months eight
months that's a long time to upkeep a
fake facade yeah that [ __ ] comes out
pretty quick quick
nah that's dude I'm pretty sure he was a
[ __ ] sociopath because I talked to
people about this because everyone it
was so many things everyone we had so
many mutual friends just because of the
MMA circuit you know we I knew this dude
from like a long time ago and I always
avoided dating him because I'm honest I
didn't want date him he just [ __ ]
claimed me which I was pissed but it was
whatever so I already knew him three
years before we started like dating and
I always avoided him because I don't
want to date within my industry and so
next thing you know he is talking to me
and stuff and when we were talking he
was telling me how he was getting his
second master's degree and [ __ ] like
that I was like oh okay so he has a
brain he's not some douchebag meathead
and stuff like that and so okay he seems
not too bad so I was like cool with him
then one day he came up to Richmond and
I was like oh yeah I'm in town and stuff
do you wanna hang out with me and my
cousin and we didn't we hung out and
stuff and then next thing you know we
hooked up and I even though it was kind
of like I felt kind of forced at the
time but it ended up being like pretty
good so I was like all right well at
least the sex was kind of good so okay
cool so we just kept kind of hooking up
for a little bit and I kind of want to
keep a secret I want to keep a secret I
don't want anyone know about it because
I didn't want to get involved with
everyone with an mm
and even though he wasn't in my gym he
was under the same franchise or the gym
I was at even though he lived like three
and a half hours away next thing you
know he ends up moving up to my gym he
moves up to my gym and he was at a party
with my teammates and on the phone he
just [ __ ] claimed me and told
everyone that I was his girlfriend and I
was just like whoa what the [ __ ] like
we're supposed to keep this [ __ ] a
secret yeah and now everyone knows
well alright cool i guess and everything
was going well at this time so i thought
it was cool and everyone liked him he
was a good liar everyone liked him
thought he was a good person and i
thought he was a good person all the way
until six months after we move in
together
we're in together two months in and then
one day we get a [ __ ] argument over
something so dumb I honestly we got in
arguments over so many things I can't
remember but I think it was one of the
times where he got angry at me because
my hair was on the floor you know how
people shed [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah he got mad because naturally my
hair shed in the bathroom floor and he
started yelling at me about that I was
like what the [ __ ] and so and we got an
argument and next thing you know he
picked me up my neck and threw me yeah
and strangled me and that was the first
time I was like in shock I I was like
I'm in an abusive relationship and I
didn't know how to get out yeah and
during this time I was like and the
crazy thing is I was I was doing well my
career at the time I was doing well in
MMA and at this time I was arguing a fan
base and woman would tell me and say
they look up to me and how strong of a
woman I am and Here I am getting abused
and it just wasn't a good look all the
way around you feel like a fraud yeah it
made me feel like I couldn't talk to
anyone I had a key to keep up that front
because it's like well these people look
up to me and then if you kind of you
kind of put into this weird situation
you feel like you don't have anybody to
talk to because you're supposed to be
everybody's role model exactly no and no
one knew about I couldn't tell my
friends
couldn't tell anyone and the few people
I did tell that I was friends with that
Jim like like I don't know if they
believe me only one guy believe me but
also the politics of it was he was the
biggest dude this dude was like 215
pounds of muscle [ __ ] oh hey he's a
big boy he's a big boy yeah like he even
though he could cut down and fight to
170 but he walked around to 15 so I was
121 at the time I'm tiny and he's a pro
fighter like with a [ __ ] am I gonna do
to him like there's nothing I could do
and so and all the people even the ones
who did believe me at the gym wouldn't
stand up for me because they were too
scared that he would beat him up beat
them up because he does he kind of just
bullies everyone at the gym and stuff so
they were too scared to piss him off and
everyone's on his [ __ ] dick because
like he's supposed to be a next UFC
prospect and [ __ ] so everyone's just
like all like oh my god Mike you know
like it's some [ __ ] so because of
that like people and it [ __ ] like it
hurt me because I was at this gym for
like five and a half years I was there
way before he was there and then so
quickly I see people's true colors and
they jump ship and take his side and say
that I'm the crazy one now I'm know like
I'm done [ __ ] like I'm so quiet and shy
they think that I'm the [ __ ] crazy
when that started but that's because he
was so good at putting up this front and
he was such a good guy
so no one believed me and the ones who
did they wouldn't stick up for me so I
felt stuck in this situation and at the
time you know I I did love him at the
time and I I guess I had abused woman
syndrome a little bit when I was there
and I guess I didn't realize the
severity of the matter and I'll and it
got to a point where one night we're
laying on the couch watching Netflix
watching this one documentary called
like who the [ __ ] did I marry on mystery
ID and one episode was about a husband
and wife and the husband was abusive and
try to leave him and he shot her in the
back of the head and killed her
and he turned around and said to me
that's what i'ma do to you if you ever
try to leave me and I took it as a joke
I'm like aha
funny like I didn't take it serious but
then a few months later like a few
months had passed a few months later so
we're watching another episode and again
he goes that's Holman duty if you ever
leave me oh my god no I was just like
yeah and the thing is and he said to me
and past before that uh if I ever get
him locked up his dad would come and
kill me and his dad was locked up for
ten years for assault and uh I started
getting a little worried I was like okay
this is months has passed obviously
you've been thinking about this [ __ ] and
then he said it again
so then the third time he said it he had
bought a gun he bought a gun and kept it
loaded in front of us in front of the
living room table where we laid and I
thought to myself oh my god this guy is
gonna kill me for real yeah and I
started he said it again the third time
and I got like kind of yeah worried now
I was like what the hell like are you
like why do you keep saying this at this
point like eight and a half months had
passed and I was like why to keep saying
this it's been eight and a half months
there's a third time you said it to me
like like are you are you trying to kill
me or something and he's like oh no I
love you I would never do that blah blah
blah and then I thought to myself
dude he's legit gonna kill me in it and
I had to figure out a way to get out of
the situation so instead I told him I
was gonna move all my summer stuff or my
winter stuff to my parents place and
move all my summer stuff in and I was
gonna switch stuff out but really I was
packing all my important stuff and he
was helping me move the boxes into my
car I had the doors open on both sides
and I had this giant ass box I can't see
where I'm going and next thing you know
he's yelling at me he's like open the
[ __ ] doors and I'm like the doors are
open and he's like open the [ __ ]
doors I'm gonna throw all your [ __ ] on
the floor and at the time I was doing
graphic design that was like kind of my
job and I had my computer in there
that's my work I was like no my computer
is another don't
roll on the ground if you're if you're
it's too heavy and can't hold it put on
top of car put it on the ground next
thing you know he goes I'm in the middle
of putting the [ __ ] in my car and as I'm
putting in
I hear him and go nope and that by time
I turn around he Chuck's all my [ __ ]
he's like 6 1 he he's like holding on up
here Chuck's it up and drops all my [ __ ]
on the ground and I'm my computer's
[ __ ] in there recycle he's [ __ ]
psycho and I was [ __ ] pissed
yeah and I'm like what the [ __ ] I just
[ __ ] told you any time I even say
anything back he gets physical he gets
in my face and he goes shut the [ __ ] up
or I will shoot you in the [ __ ] face
and when we go to court I will just tell
the judge that I thought you were
intruder and that's why I shot ya he
sent all that [ __ ] and I'm just like
thinking to myself oh my god how long
did he think about all that like how do
you think of that and then all that [ __ ]
like obviously even think about that
[ __ ] and so I told I'm like I'm leaving
and I put the car in my nation he breaks
the key out of my ignition cuts my hand
open because he was pulling it out of my
hand and luckily at the time there was a
police officer patrolling that area he
was can I help you is there a problem
here and I was a guy he won't let me
leave and [ __ ] left never turned back
went all the way back home to
Charlottesville Virginia where my
parents were and I was working on my
parents place for three and a half
months saving up money to come out to
California yeah and then from that
people got word that I was moving out
here and he heard that I was moving out
here and so he tried to keep some pull
some [ __ ] to keep me from leaving
because he kept apologizing after and
trying to get back together with me
but I kept telling him no and then two
weeks before I was in come out here he
pulls some [ __ ] and went to the cops
and told them that I was the one who
attacked him and trying to get me locked
up in jail and I was like what the [ __ ]
and so I went and spent all the money I
had saved up on the lawyer I went to the
police place to buy all the car logs of
all the times I
call the cops on him and had the cops
come and escort me out and I had to do
that because I wasn't gonna take a
chance on getting locked up and the
reason why that was is because one of
the times that he picked me up on my
neck and strangled me he held me down
and choked me and toy I almost passed
out
I remember right before I was about to
black out I thought to myself oh my god
I'm gonna die tonight
if I don't do anything and instinctually
I grabbed his face and I pushed it and
my nail cut the side of his nose and it
was bleeding I called the cops on him to
get them in and the stupid-ass cop
they're supposed to separate you guys
and ask you questions separately but the
bitch-ass dumbass cop he asked me do you
want to press charges right in front of
him he's standing right there and he's
standing behind the cop and he goes well
do you like mouthing the words well do
you you want to press charges on me huh
you want to press charges and at the
moment I was thinking [ __ ] everything
[ __ ] my career like [ __ ] this I'm gonna
press charges imma give him locked up
and [ __ ] everything but then when I saw
him I got intimidated and I told him no
I was like no and then though a female
cop took him outside and asked him
questions separately of course he
[ __ ] lied and said I attacked him and
then she came in and she gave me an
attitude and she goes he told me that
you he uh you were the one that attacked
him I was like what the [ __ ] oh I just
say what the [ __ ] I was like what no I
did not like I'm the one who called you
guys I'm like he strangled me and I
pushed his face away and that's why I
cut him and I'm like it's like you're
not gonna see bruises when you get
strangled it shows up hours later yeah
and so she told me I was like what the
hell I'm like that's not what happened
and then she told me to shut up or all
she's gonna take me to jail Wow
I was like are you [ __ ] serious like
are you [ __ ] serious like I can't
believe I'm getting the table's turned
on me yeah because of his lies and I
wasn't gonna ruin my whole life in
future because of this [ __ ] so I
went in and and I knew at this time
already when the abuse started happening
I knew that our relationship was
and in court yeah so one of the times
that another time he [ __ ] he took a
belt and with me for 30 minutes straight
and I secretly recorded it on my phone
oh Sh I was gonna I was gonna say like
did you ever record any of these
interactions because like this is
because this happened so repetitively
it's like well now you got a you got a
[ __ ] read up on this [ __ ] you know
yeah I uh I recorded the whole thing
when he was like whipping me and [ __ ]
and calling me a [ __ ] dog and and
when I went to court I play that in
court and what sucked was uh I had to
play it and from my dad I was like
everything so um like sorry no it's okay
um so it was like really hard cuz my
parents like I had to keep that [ __ ]
secret and uh then I was like my dad had
to really hear about all this [ __ ] and
uh so after that I put a restraining
order on him and all the money that had
saved up to go to California I had like
$3,200 at the time it all went to court
fees and lawyers and everything and um
after that I came out to California with
$800 [ __ ]
yeah and when I came out I had no job no
friends like I didn't know anyone like
nothing I have no one out here so I just
came out here and my parents thought
everything was fine and but really I
came out with a [ __ ] car my mom had this
BMW and the thing was the BMW was a 2001
and you know BMW have all these
electrical problems so it's like the car
it looked nice cuz she kept it nice it's
a silver ass BMW and so I'm getting
harassed everywhere my car is breaking
down in every [ __ ] time I break down
just happens to be in Compton or
Inglewood like it's in some [ __ ]
place and I'm so sure like people are
bothering me and stuff and like $400
here $400 here you know money just went
away so quick next thing you know I had
nothing I was sleeping out of my car
and I just had to work random jobs to
try and make money cuz it was so hard to
get a [ __ ] job out here and because I
was just working and random bars and I
was modeling here and there I used to
like import modeling and whatever so
sell some merchandise here and there and
make some random money here and there
and that would keep me going until you
know I was kind of up on my feet until
finally I you know I worked over for a
while and then I worked at this music
studio and start getting more money and
then when I start getting more money I
ended up investing all my money in my
training so I still stayed in my car
because I was it was enough to be able
to do both you know actually no at the
time I was investing oh I forgot I also
got scammed I think I think you're lucky
this is like saddest story I've ever
heard of my life [ __ ] over dude yeah
like I came out here and I was I decided
to quit MMA because I I didn't want to
run into him because you know I'm am a
circle small yeah I don't want to run
into him and I was so angry with the MMA
community because I'm like everyone's
like turn my back on me to take sides
with this [ __ ] like I don't want
to deal with this community anymore and
I [ __ ] wanna just pursue music cuz
honestly that was my first love I was
pursuing music and so I came out here
for some music and then I think I got
[ __ ] over by this fake-ass producer
that was taking tons of money from me
so all my money that I made I gave it to
him gave to him to a point where I just
couldn't anymore and then one of my
friends Cub Swanson he was talking to me
Oh jamika when I went out to Albuquerque
at Greg Jackson's oh yeah yeah yeah so
he's always been really cool with me and
he just gave me advice like you know I
should get back into MMA and so because
of him saying that I decided to go back
and train and so I that's when I joined
up with black house and started you know
spending all my money in there and I was
sleeping on my car until it got to a
point where I got enough money to be
able to have a place to stay and go
Train and then next thing you know end
up signed in a v2v after that
I [ __ ] crazy I mean to experience
with like it's weird because you know I
think our parents always want us to like
reach out and ask for their